[Music]
thank you
next what is behind this strange
obsession with Philip Schofield asked
Douglas Murray in this week's magazine
is it a distraction from the bigger
problems facing Britain he sees me now
to discuss
so Douglas in this week's magazine you
write about Philip Schofield what
inspired you to choose this topic for
your column
well obviously I missed an incredibly
inspirational subject no I mean really
it was just the fact that I have been
astonished amazed that the last 10 days
of news in Britain has been so almost
completely blackout wall-to-wall Phillip
Schofield I I said recently in my column
I didn't think that the British media
could get more absurd than their
obsession with uh the speeding awareness
course that the Home Secretary may have
to go on and to the extent that British
journalists from the BBC and ITV and Sky
were flown out to the G7 in Tokyo where
they used the opportunity of being in
Japan to ask Rishi sunak about suela
brotherman's speeding awareness course
and I said there I mean what gives here
this Obsession the British media with
these minutiae stories you know I've
written about this in the magazine
before in the political field we had the
weeks and weeks of controversy over
Dominic Robb and the manner in which he
threw a cherry tomato into a bin a a
throw that resounded across Whitehall
apparently and terrified the Civil
Service who then said they were bullied
and then you get all the sort of uh you
know normal sort of white call covering
journalists obsessed with this how can
we get rid of the Deputy Prime Minister
then they move on to the Home Secretary
and now it seems as I always say there's
always another Circle to The Inferno it
seems that the the Packers moved on to
the this morning couch and as I say in
my column uh uh I hope it's no insult to
uh Holly Willoughby and Phillip
Schofield to say this but less than one
percent of the population tuned into
this morning
so what's the explanation for
wall-to-wall coverage uh about
these two really very uninteresting
people
I mean well Douglas I mean some might
say you a bit of a snob though if you're
not interested in Breakfast Television I
mean what's wrong with people being
allowed to sort of discuss the ins and
outs and these sort of people that they
live in the spot the toilet spotlighter
what's wrong with us discussing uh
they're full from Grace
yeah no I mean then some people may say
a bit of a snob for uh for this but
there we are
um uh I really don't mind the exhibition
leveled at me if it's to do with not
wanting to be completely obsessed with
uh morning television that really people
aren't interested in anyway as I say
because you can tell from the viewing
figures anyway no it is really just that
there is it is what I described as I
think a sort of um it's an odd activity
a displacement activity going on in
modern Britain that is is reflected in
other countries as well but I think is
nowhere as parochial as it is in the UK
a weird displacement activity with
getting on with other things like you
know tearing up the ITV morning
scheduling offices uh
um what are we really doing when we're
doing what is really happening when we
get these National obsessions of who
knew what when
what is it that we're doing and my my
exploration as I say in the column is
we're just distracting ourselves because
all the really big issues in our country
we completely fail to deal with I mean
you know I just watched uh I mean it's
not the biggest issue in the country but
I just watched another labor politician
failed to say that women by and large
don't have penises they get themselves
into these Middle Ages like uh
contortions on these questions of of
heresy and dogma and uh but if you get
them onto anything important ask anyone
in the cabinet or Shadow cabinet about
the about energy policy about housing
policy about immigration policy about
fiscal policy about borrowing debt
unfunded pensions liabilities inflation
you name it
what do they have to say
what do any of them have to say I mean
labor always tells us that they want to
debate no they don't because they don't
have anything to say no none of them
have anything to say about the big
issues going on and as I say I think
there is a weird displacement activity
in modern Britain which is let's play
this game of toppling person after
person politician after politician and
eventually toppling everyone off the
morning sofas uh and then we think we've
achieved something we haven't
I I mean I'm sure would be no uh I'm
sure you're interested to know Douglas
that uh MPS already said on the culture
committee that they're going to call in
itv's bosses uh next week to discuss the
issue in Parliament so uh not sure what
you'd make of that as displacement
activities as I say circle after Circle
I tell you
I mean but you're right in the column
that is a sort of singularly British
Obsession you spend a lot of time in
America and traveling elsewhere around
the world why do you think this is such
a British thing sort of focusing on the
trivial rather than the fundamental
well uh it says this there's this
question
what do we do
we do it we tried to LEAP out of the EU
in 2016 and have had years of
contortions since
um the the attempt to sort of reverse
decline uh keeps running into a block or
a wall uh Liz truss said she wanted
reverse Decline and lasted about a
fortnight so the decline teams back on
the agenda
um if you ask a politician in America uh
what they want to do on the left they'll
say they want social justice and so on
and on the right they'll say they want
to build the economy
well I mean I happen to think that the
latter is more plausible and a better
answer you know Rising tide and all of
that but they they do sort of they have
a plan which is the American economy
should be going gangbusters
um what is the plan in Britain exactly
I mean do any of them know that can
Pierce Dharma give a plausible
explanation of what the country would do
under his leadership uh
can Richie soon act to that uh when it
comes to that can he actually say what
his vision of Britain is I I think the
answer is no and and that there's
something very revealing in that and and
into that void steps all of this trivia
and what I regard as being fundamentally
distracting uh activities
well quite and I wonder perhaps do you
think that this shows that Britain is
just simply not a serious country now
well I think we haven't been for some
time but uh I I I think that we really
need to get out of this
this rut of thinking that if if we just
if if the media moves the latest
non-scandal Scandal along a little bit
and gets another scalp then you know we
get anywhere we don't we don't
um doesn't improve education for anyone
doesn't improve
um housing opportunities for anyone
doesn't improve the job market it
doesn't do anything really
um and so yes it it is it is a strange
it's a strange British Obsession and you
know I'm all for trivia uh in in certain
uh you know quantities but the trivia
cannot outweigh the serious stuff and as
I say I mean it's just a very bad sign
for a country that you end up being so
willing to be distracted from
distraction by Distraction
and do you write in the column um
Douglas that you think it's about sort
of misdirected anger misdirected emotion
that all this sort of stuff has
channeled into these quite trivial
matters I mean do you think that as you
say partly because we're wanting to be
distracted that we are sort of missing
uh bigger genuine scandals in this
country I know you've um written before
very in the magazine about you know the
ones on the during the troubles with
Northern Ireland I mean do you think the
sort of similar scandals are being
missed because we're simply focusing on
completely the wrong issues
well I think that's undoubtedly the case
and as I say several recent columns I
tried to draw people's attention to this
you know as I I said fairly often
recently what would we be doing if we
weren't doing this
uh what would the media be doing what
would government be doing if if if if if
Government didn't keep on getting
clogged up by these sorts of you know
cake gate speed gate everything's a damn
gate you know and everyone thinks it's
so original when they put gate after
anything
um and you know what would the
government be concentrating on what what
might it be achieving
um if the answer is not much more then
there's even more trouble that we're in
than I thought but but my belief is is
that we we just are horribly
misdirecting our energies and yes uh
there's there's doubt because scandals
going on there always are
um and there are scandals that are of
significance I mean you just mentioned
Northern Ireland the steak Knife
controversies come back up again I don't
think that
outside of Northern Ireland one in a
thousand households know anything about
that maybe they don't need to but it'll
probably be a more intelligent Scandal
to look at than the Gordon the gopher's
former sofa mate Scandal
um I I I I think that but as I say that
the main thing isn't isn't you know
where are the scandals that it's a very
post-watergate thing that that
journalists think that their job is to
find all the scandals that exist expose
them and then win all of the awards it's
a very it's a very sort of
post-watergate way of doing journalism
sometimes there are scandals then they
should be exposed but the whole of
Politics the whole country isn't just a
set of scandals waiting to be uncovered
you know um but but there is some
fundamental failure of the media in this
but the fundamental failure of the media
is a fundamental failure of government
it's a reflection of that which is the
the fact that government seems not to be
able to do in Britain any of the things
we need it to do have asked it to do and
want it to do government can't seem to
do that uh it waits for for court
judgments on things before moving ahead
of anything because it seems the
government isn't in charge you know
Strasbourg still is and and on certain
matters of the immigration and and so on
they wait for decisions to be made
elsewhere to allow them to make a
decision
so yes then the Press
reflects that by also engaging in sort
of past time trivia uh I think it's a
it's it's very very sad because there
are huge issues we could be addressing
at the end of my column this week I
mentioned some of the sort of cosmic
issues we could be addressing
um but we're nowhere near that and I I
wish that it was just possible obviously
what I'm trying to do to encourage my
fellow countrymen it just rise raise
their eyes slightly
off the level of the morning television
sofa and on to the things that could
really
matter and improve things and help our
country because otherwise this this is
just going to be a perennial game of
distraction and it and it's one that I
find exhausting I suspect that most of
the people engaged find exhausting and
you know is tiring us out and wasting
our energies which need to be expended
elsewhere
we're talking if you're tired energy so
my final question Douglas uh there's now
a vacancy on this morning sofa will you
be uh throwing your hat in the ring
um no I it sound it sounds like a proper
Viper's Nest
um and um uh I don't mind getting up
early but I don't love it
um and um no I I think I think I think
I'm not in the running
um which obviously saddens me deeply
James but on the other hand leaves the
field opener for you oh I I think I've
got my place here at The Spectator with
you Douglas thank you for joining us
great pleasure
[Music]